Hi guys.
I will cut right to the point:
I am taking a hiatus for about a month
and the reason is I'm not very happy with the videos that I've been making.
And it's not that I'm burnt out on making videos.
I- totally the opposite.
I'm actually more eager than I ever have been
to make videos and that's kind of part of the problem.
I love making videos.
I-I-I-I'm more than happy to work non-stop
on something that I'm proud of.
I'm a workaholic. I'll work every day, bro.
I don't take weekends, I don't take vacations.
and I know this may sound strange to you guys
because like the schedule is super wonky
so if I'm working non-stop then why are videos so inconsistent?
I'm basically completely absent from social media
And in a weird way it could seem like I'm doing nothing at all,
when in fact I'm trying to do more than ever
at making the videos better
or making me more satisfied with the videos that I'm doing.
But without a way to exceed my own expectations
in what I'm doing and what I'm posting in the videos that I'm making,
I don't feel like I'm ever improving.
So then on and on it goes
that I keep adding more and more effort into what I do
and then it's this cyclical thing where I go,
"oh, it's not enough" or "oh, I need to work harder at this"
or "I need to work better this or improve this one thing".
And yet, this kind of cycle has been going on for about a year now
where I continually am unhappy with the videos that I make.
I try to solve the problem with brute force effort
rather than creativity.
In the end, I just don't want to settle
on the videos that I'm really proud of and really excited for
and really happy with.
And the videos that make me laugh that I make,
I don't want those to be the exception to the rule.
I want those to be the rule.
Now this doesn't mean that I'm going to be disappearing.
A hiatus doesn't mean that I'm taking a vacation.
I just told you I don't do that.
I'm actually gonna be filming and planning and writing
and collaborating every single day leading up to this.
And it also doesn't mean that I'm going to be completely vacant on content.
Like I'm probably gonna be more active
on social media than ever over these next few weeks,
just because I will be goofing with you guys.
I'll be talking with you guys,
I will be trying to get feedback from you guys,
I will be like in tune with the community again,
which is something that I very much miss.
And also there will still be content during this time,
not a lot, but there will still be content.
We have our charity live stream on the 30th of November we're doing,
we still have the big project that is coming out,
and I will tell you a release date just to give you something to look forward to;
that is coming out Friday the 13th of October,
and it's gonna be pretty cool.
So you can look forward to that.
And, obviously, we're still doing the tour.
Like the tour is definitely still happening
and I can't wait to do that.
I can't wait to be performing for you guys with my friends
and even then we're gonna be out there
and we're gonna be filming cool stuff while we're doing it
and I'm gonna be talking with Bob and Wade and Tyler and Ethan.
I'm gonna be talking with all those guys about
like what videos can really like
really make me passionate about it,  you know.
What videos can I really burn for it?
What videos can I really like really strive to improve upon?
And what videos can I like surprise you guys?
'Cause I know I can make really cool stuff.
It's just that you know my focus
hasn't been able to be 100% dedicated.
Like I'm an obsessive person.
I want to go to bed with a smile on my face
knowing that what I made is something that people can remember,
something that people will cherish,
something that -I'll- cherish you know.
And that's what's important.
So anyway, to recap: I'm going on hiatus.
I'll be back. October 23rd is when I'm aiming to go back.
That is the date, set in stone.
So you guys can count on
seeing the new stuff starting to roll out on the 23rd of October.
And still doing the charity live stream,
still doing the big projects, still doing the tour.
And it should be a lot of fun.
So thank you guys so much for understanding.
If you are upset about this,
please record yourself screaming and panicking in the streets
and post it all over social media
as is the usual Markiplier crisis response.
So thank you all so much for watching
and it may take a bit, but I promise...
wink wonk...
I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye